توتر متصاعد بعد الاعتداء الاسرائيلي على
معتكفي الاقصى حمله الانتخابيه اكبر
المستفيدين من محاكمته وانقاذوا سيد دفنت
على قيد الحياه في البرازيل هذه الاخبار
وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
فيما لا يزال المسجد الاقصى يشهد توترا
متصاعدا بين قوات الاحتلال والفلسطينيين
الذين اصيب واعتقل منهم عشرات اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي شن غارات استهدفت مواقع في
قطاع غزه وستحذير الفصائل الفلسطينيه من
عواقب التصعيد في القدس عشرته الفلسطينيين
كان اصيبوا بالاختناق فجر اليوم في صدمه
مع الشرطه الاسرائيليه لدى اقتحامها
المصلى القبلي في المسجد الاقصى ومهاجمتها
للمعتكفين هناك فيما اثار الاقتحام اذانه
عربيه ودوليه واسعه ودعوه الى عدم التصعيد
يبدو ان الحمله الانتخابيه للرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب كانت اكبر
المستفيدين من الملاحقه الجنائيه له فبعد
مثوله امام محكمه منهاتن وجهت اليه لائحه
طويله من الالتهابات كشفت ترامب انه جمع
اكثر من عشره ملايين دولار لحملتها
الانتخابيه وذلك منذ اعلانه لائحه الاتهام
التي نفاها جمله وتفصيلا اما مصدر تلك
الاموال فات على شكل تبرعات من مناصريه
دعما لترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2024
خصوصا بعدما روجت حملته عبر موقعها على
الانترنت لقميص عليه صوره وهميه موقوفا
وتحتها عباره لست مذنبا
في صدفه اقرب الى المعجزه حياه جديده كتبت
لسيده برازيليه بعد ان تم العثور عليها
مدفونه في قبر وهي على قيد الحياه في
مقبره جنوب شرقي البرازي التحقيقات كشفت
ان الضحيه تعرضت للضرب والسحل قبل ان يلقى
بها في القبر حيث ظلت حبيسه في لمده عشر
ساعات قبل ان ينتبه حفروا القبور هناك الى
وجودها بعد سماع صراخاتها من داخل القبر
ثم اوقفت السلطه البرازيليه رجلين على
خلفيه الحادث
معجزه اخرى لكن هذه المره في روسيا حيث
انقذ الحظ رجلا في مدينه الروسيه بعد ان
سقط من الطابق التاسع عشر ليرتطم بسياره
رباعيه الدفع كانت متوقفه تحت المبنى
الغريب في الحادثه ان الرجل وبعد سقوطهم
من هذا الارتفاع الشاهق نهضت وبدا يسير
على قدميه بشكل طبيعي وكانه لم يصب باي
اذى في مقاله شهود عيان انهم سمعوا الرجل
يصرخ من شرفه او هي شرفه شقته قبل سقوطه
على السياره
خبرنا الاخير من عالم الفضاء حيث رصد
تلسكوب جيمس ويب العملاق ابعد مجره مكتشف
على الاطلاق تشكلت في العصور الاولى للكون
بعد 320 مليون سنه فقط من الانفجار العظيم
المجرات كلما كانت بعيده اي حديثه العهد
زادت صعوبه اكتشافها نظرا لضعف الاشاره
الضوئيه المتاتيه منها البيانات المسجله
عبر تيلسكوب جيمس ويب حددت مجرات كثيره قد
تكون اشاراتها الضوئيه ضمن النطاق الاشعه
دون الحمراء وهي موجات طول غير مرئيه
بالعين البشريه وتتيح مراقبتها الغوص في
اعماق الماضي السح